E aí
se você já parou para pensar nas
escolhas que você fez
alguma dessas suas escolhas é a sua
missão de vida eu te convido aqui a
pensar um pouco sobre essas questões
sou Letícia Marone psicóloga mãe da
Alice casada eu acredito que algumas
coisas na vida da gente a gente escolhe
e outras tantas coisas a gente recebe
como missão
eu acho que eu tive a sorte grande sabe
na minha vida tive essas duas coisas
juntas as minhas maiores escolhas são na
verdade minha grande missão eu tô
falando aqui sobre a maternidade e sobre
a psicologia
e eu sempre quis ser mãe
desde criança eu brincava e dizia que eu
ia ter filhos eu me imaginava dessa
forma eu tinha certeza que isso um dia
acontecer mas as minhas brincadeiras de
casinha de ter filhinhos eu jamais
imaginei que eu teria uma filha
deficiente
a maternidade foi uma escolha mas a
maternidade atípica eu não tenho dúvida
de que é uma missão de vida na minha
infância eu ouvi as pessoas dizendo que
eu era uma criança sensível
emotiva vivia chorando Minhas irmãs até
brincavam que eu não ia ter cílios do
tanto que eu chorava e realmente eu não
tenho cílios até hoje a psicologia eu
escolhi como profissão
mas eu queria mais do que isso eu queria
me doar Eu queria cuidar Então veio a
psicologia hospitalar que é uma missão
na minha vida a minha maternidade
aconteceu de forma muito rápida logo
após o meu casamento poucos meses depois
já estava grávida ea é só alegria foi só
felicidade na nossa vida
a grávida a gente escuta As pessoas
sempre perguntando E aí o que que você
quer menino e uma menina e eu sempre
responde assim ela tanto faz eu quero
que venha com saúde mas eu mal sabia o
que estava por vir
e no meu sétimo mês de gestação no
ultrassom de rotina eu percebi um
semblante diferente do médico e esse
médico me deu então a notícia que foi a
pior notícia da minha vida
e ele me falou assim olha a Letícia
sua bebê tem uma má formação do cérebro
aquela notícia tirou meu chão
aliás eu sempre dizia que queria ter uma
filha com saúde não é assim eu tive
então que me dá conta de que eu teria
uma criança diferente
Oi
Alice tem baixa visão atraso Global do
desenvolvimento ou atraso cognitivo e
motor
Alice tem paralisia cerebral é uma
criança cadeirante e eu senti medo muito
medo com tudo aquilo
com muito medo muita insegurança muita
frustração
muita tristeza assim que dá soubemos da
deficiência da Alice nós começamos a
cuidar de todos os detalhes para que ela
tivesse um acompanhamento desde o início
da sua vida
Oi e a gente pensou Então em tem uma
pediatra na sala de parto para acolher
Alice No momento do Nascimento
nós procuramos muito por uma pediatra e
Nós escolhemos uma que tinha uma imensa
experiência técnica um conhecimento
muito grande
mas ela não tinha nenhum contato com ser
humano
numa consulta Faltando 15 dias para o
nascimento da Alice
a médica pediatra que acompanha lá na
sala de parto me disse assim olha a
Letícia
os piores dias da sua vida estão só
começando
e a sua filha não vai te dar uma
maternidade cor-de-rosa cheia de
coraçõezinhos como toda mãe espera
e
depois eu vi aquela falar daquela médica
naquele mesmo dia nós decidimos que ela
não seria a médica que acompanharia
Alice no seu nascimento ela não merecia
esse momento de lá para cá foram quatro
anos muito intensos diversos
especialistas muitos médicos muitas
consultas exames
Alice fez três cirurgias Teve crises
convulsivas E finalizou essas crises com
tratamento a nesse ele se o dieta
cetogênica que ela faz os até os dias de
hoje e a gente precisava muito descobrir
o diagnóstico da Alice Foi então que
veio tão esperado diagnóstico Alice tem
uma doença Rara chamada deficiência de
piruvato desidrogenase
provavelmente você nunca ouviu falar
sobre isso né Eu também nunca tinha
escutado falar a deficiência de piruvato
desidrogenase é uma doença rara que tem
a sigla pdh um é um erro inato do
metabolismo uma doença genética mas que
não tem fator hereditário e não tem uma
causa específica para ter acontecido
aconteceu porque tinha que acontecer
Alice tinha que ser assim e ela tinha
que ser minha foi um alívio receber esse
diagnóstico e saber exatamente quem é
Alice poder oferecer a ela tudo que ela
precisa depois esse diagnóstico vieram
muitos sorrisos da Alice muitas
gargalhadas muita alegria um
desenvolvimento melhor e para nós uma
maior aceitação e maior resiliência
Oi e aí a descoberta do grande amor da
minha vida e minha grande missão que é
ser mãe atípica além da maternidade
atípica com decorrer do tempo foi
ganhando espaço na minha vida também é
psicologia hospitalar quanto a gratidão
eu tenho por cada pessoa que passou pela
minha vida nesses 19 anos de profissão
foram muitas histórias muitas famílias
muitas pessoas mas nunca nunca o socorro
emocional foi tão importante tão urgente
e necessário quanto agora no momento de
pandemia o sofrimento EA dor dentro de
um hospital em época de pandemia é
Avassalador nesses quase dois anos
diversos pacientes passaram por mim com
diversas situações
econômicas financeiras sociais
familiares diversas condições clínicas
diversas idades
é tudo muito diferente
e pra covid-19 não existe regra Mas sabe
uma coisa que todos os pacientes têm em
comum muito medo e impotência eu vi
vários pacientes serem incubados vários
outros se reabilitando vi inúmeras
famílias se despedaçarem E tantas outras
se unir em cada vez mais
e eu vi a morte diversas vezes mas eu vi
inúmeros pacientes renascendo no meu
trabalho eu pude oferecer a minha escuta
o toque das mãos Um abraço eu acolhi fiz
vídeo chamadas eu fui ponte e números
pacientes passaram por mim nesses dois
anos mas um deles me trouxe a certeza de
que algumas das minhas escolhas são
lições de vida
eu vou trazer um relato aqui sobre Maria
e João esses não são os nomes reais das
pessoas que eu atendi
e não foi um paciente que chegou o
hospital e desde o primeiro contato me
chamou atenção era um rapaz jovem 30
anos sem comorbidades com sonhos pela
frente muitos ideais
o João precisou ser internado e pouco
tempo depois ele teve diagnóstico
covid-19
e
ele ficou muito assustado tinha muito
medo Muita ansiedade
e os médicos Então optaram por trazer
Maria que era sua noiva para permanecer
com o João uma estratégia para reduzir a
sua ansiedade
a Maria ficou com João enquanto ela pode
assim como ela já vinha fazendo nos
últimos 12 anos de relacionamento que
eles tinham
é só que o João teve uma piora e
precisou ir para UTI a partir desse
momento Maria não poderia mais
acompanhar o João sabia disso e na sua
ida para a UTI ir ele gritava muito
chamava muito pelo nome da Maria
O João estava Muito angustiado e aquela
angústia dele também era nossa João e
Maria tinha uma conexão muito grande uma
afinidade imensa um amor enorme e muitos
planos em comum eles se casariam dentro
de 2 meses
e na UTI João tinha seu celular era uma
forma de ele se sente mais acolhido
menos Solitário ele tem as pessoas
próximas a ele ainda que de uma forma
remota João diariamente conversava com
Maria por mensagens falava comigo falava
com diversas outras pessoas com quem ele
queria nas nossas conversas João sempre
me falava sobre seus medos sobre querer
ir embora para casa se recuperar falava
da saudade que ele sentia da Maria e
falava dos planos que ele tinha para
depois do hospital Inclusive o seu
casamento e a Maria Maria queria que
tudo aquilo acontecesse
é mas infelizmente João foi entubado a
partir daquele momento
o meu cuidado com Maria se intensificou
Maria tinha uma mistura de sentimentos
hora ela tinha muita certeza da melhora
do João muita fé ao mesmo tempo que ela
tinha muita insegurança e muito medo
infelizmente após 22 dias de internação
João não resistiu à convite
a lidar com aqueles sentimentos da Maria
e do João durante aquele processo de
internação foi muito difícil ao passo
que também foi muito difícil lidar com
as minhas próprias emoções com tudo
aquilo eu fiz o que eu pude
e oferecia me escuta e eu acolhi fiz
vídeo chamadas
sustentava A Fé Esperança deles em
diversos momentos em vários outros
momentos Eu ofereci o meu silêncio e
quanto ao meu trabalho na psicologia
hospitalar hoje eu não tenho dúvida de
que essa minha escolha é uma lição de
vida como eu falei lá no início eu sou
grata o que eu consegui unir na minha
vida as escolhas que eu fiz a minha
missão nesse mundo tro1 eu trouxe aqui
hoje esses dois casos para ilustrar
Exatamente isso a minha maternidade
atípica e a psicologia hospitalar com
certeza são que traz sentido à minha
vida hoje eu vejo que assim como na
minha maternidade e
na história de Maria João um sonho
também foi interrompido aquele sonho
realizado ele não é mais possível
e com a vinda da Alice eu precisei
ressignificar a minha maternidade foi
preciso que eu fizesse o luto daquela
filha idealizada e Sonhada porque eu
então pudesse aceitar a filha que o jer
Ava e com a Maria também vai ter que ser
assim vai ser preciso que ela faça o seu
luto para conseguir dar novo sentido e
nova cor da sua vida a E por falar em
cor eu aproveito aqui para poder deixar
um recado para aquela médica com quem eu
fiz a consulta Faltando 15 dias para o
nascimento da Alice eu queria dizer a
ela que a minha maternidade é assim uma
maternidade cor-de-rosa cheia de
corações rins e como é